[Music]
[Applause]
Hall of Fame broadcaster Alan Michaels
the play-by-play voice of Thursday Night
Football Al will be on the call for the
Vikings at the eagles with Kirk
herbstreet that'll be a kickoff at 8 15
Eastern good to see you again your
reaction to what you saw last night with
the pregame festivities and Aaron
Rodgers brief appearance
you know I have so much stuff rolling
around in my head that I can't get rid
of all I thought about at first was we
did a game on Sunday Night Football five
years ago at Lambo Chicago went into
Green Bay Bailey it just signed Khalil
Mack Matt Nagy was making his debut as
the head coach
Aaron Rodgers goes down in the first
half and they caught him back into the
locker room and it looks like the season
is over and maybe it's the Bears time
the Bears LED 17 to nothing at the half
they LED 20 to nothing early in the
third who comes back from The Locker
Room Aaron
and the other thing that popped into my
headband crazily enough was that Carl
Jeffers who was the ref last night was
the ref that night in Lambeau and Green
Bay came from behind and won the game
and Aaron of course will not have a
great year so that was the first thought
I had okay maybe it's not so bad it
didn't look so Insidious but we know
it's a lot differently today but uh man
oh man what a game that was last night
and what an ending and you know that's
pretty much why everybody loves football
because that was that was just crazy top
to bottom and you have to be careful
when you're calling a game of not
speculating on an injury
how do you do that in the moment where
you see something like that without
trying to get maybe ahead of yourself a
little bit
because I've learned and I think most
announcers have learned through the
years
we're not doctors we are not
um and I think it was a Scott Van Pelt
last night said we have all of these
internet doctors yeah everybody's
everybody is making their
decision as to what what the situation
is
I'll never forget there was an announcer
I don't want to mention his Navy she's a
good good buddy but it was in a game
probably in the early 90s Reggie Roby
the kicker for Miami got run into he was
laid out and the analyst said that is
not arthroscopic surgery that is
reconstructed that's how he analyzed
that play oh boy Reggie Roby kicked the
next week
so no we all know you we're not doctors
we're not uh and you just let it play
out and then get the information from
the team it's as simple as that I didn't
know how long it took for you to check
the Thursday night schedule for the
number of appearances by the New York
Jets did you do that uh soon after
Rogers was carted off yeah we yeah we um
we know we have two
so you know it's not a good day for um
for the amazonians right now because the
big game this year was going to be the
Black Friday game yeah so there's a day
after Thanksgiving and what's the game
Miami at the Jets okay so we'll still be
there and who knows I mean maybe Zach
Wilson becomes the story of the year you
know that that defense is good I mean I
don't think that team is going to
necessarily just fall apart yeah they
proved that last night they made a good
team
the defense was fantastic obviously
priest Hall looks like the real deal
that catch by Wilson was insane they've
got some good players good players good
coaching and I think you know the Jets
will just regroup as they did last night
show some resilience and who knows
what's going to happen I mentioned this
to start the show trying to recall the
highest of highs and lowest of lows in a
game with Rogers going out with the
American flag the spotlights on him and
then four plays in his season is done
and a lot of people have brought up a
lot of examples the Falcons up 28-3 in
the Super Bowl
um we mentioned the game that you called
Malcolm Butler with the interception at
the goal line because Seattle is going
to win that Super Bowl
um right Bill Buckner in 86 with the Red
Sox or the Bartman uh game
do you have uh a memory there well you
know the Seattle game with Malcolm
Butler I did you think it was over
well I thought it it looked like it was
going to be over and I was only shocked
that you know that that play was the the
play that was cold which was a pass over
the middle into traffic and I always
thought that um you know second guessing
that if you have Russell Wilson at that
point in his career you roll him out uh
maybe he runs into the end zone or you
throw it away it's only second down yeah
still have two more two more plays but
that that was stunning and then um there
was another stunner in the uh I did the
St Louis Tennessee Super Bowl after the
99 season which ain't been on the one
yard line that game was you know 16 to
nothing Rams Titans caught him Ransom
believed on an Isaac Bruce you know 70
some odd yard touchdown pass Here Comes
McNair and and the Titans and then the
game ends on a one-yard line great
Tackle by Mike Jones and that's how the
Rams walked off the field with the Super
Bowl but you know there were so many
down to me through the years that it's
great and that you know why do we love
sports because we're talking about all
the exhilarating moments
week one of the NFL season what
storyline do you think is sustainable
out of all these results
there were some interesting results I
mean Cincinnati is not that bad let's
face it that was kind of a one-off I
mean the Bengals are going to be I have
to assume they're going to be fine
um the one surprise to me was the Rams
where everybody thought you know this is
a team they're a bad team and people
even talking about tanking which I just
think is stupid talk anyway teams don't
tank these guys go out there to play
they don't tank
so I thought you know the Rams it's
funny because they happen to run into
Sean McVay uh a week before the the game
on Sunday and he said
I think we're going to win the game
he was that confident nobody knows who's
playing for them anymore right Cooper
cup is is on injured reserve you know
what was Stafford going to do after he
got hurt last year he got you know two
two at well uh emerges they've got guys
you've never heard of and they pretty
much dominated that game so that was a
big surprise for me I think uh Tampa Bay
and I watched that whole game to prepare
for the um for the Vikings uh in our
game on Thursday night and that's one of
those games where the Vikings really had
it in their hands they were controlling
the game and all of a sudden Tampa Bay
is just hanging in hanging in and the
next thing you know they're walking off
with a victory so as usual you know you
get three four or five stories every
week that uh that are great and uh it'll
keep us going until Thursday night
we're talking Al Michaels uh he'll have
Thursday night's game it's the Eagles
and the Vikings what is your curiosity
level with Kirk Cousins
uh I've you know known him and have met
with them a lot I think he's a very good
guy I really like him and I think I
think a lot of people got to know him in
that quarterback series I thought he was
very human uh he's he's a very decent
guy he's a guy he's one of those guys
who he's just kind of
he's he's in the middle he's not people
don't think I'm as great they don't
think about him as terrible he's got
that um that cross the bear about can't
you know can't win the The Prime Time
games blah blah blah blah blah but that
could end in a Flash you never know it's
like you know Phil Mickelson didn't win
a major and then all of a sudden he won
a bunch of him
um I don't know what Kirk is a he's one
of the better quarterbacks in the league
there's no question about it he now has
maybe the best receiver in the league
and they went on and drafted another
receipt Radisson has scored a touchdown
the other day at the USC
he's got some points they let down and
cook though I'm not sure they have a
running game but I think you know
cousins is the kind of guy who
one of these years and I hope for his
sake I'm just like I say he's if you
know him you like him a lot he's a good
good guy and I think he gets um an
unfair shake from time to time
remember when you lost the Super Bowl it
felt like you fell into an abyss uh that
right you know we looked at that team
they lost and then they never got back
to the Super Bowl but you know here you
have the Eagles who could have easily
won that Super Bowl
um how do you uh what have you seen so
far where you're gonna expect this or
look for this on Thursday night
number one you've got a fantastic
quarterback in Jalen hurts
you've got a really good defense I think
the interesting thing with them is that
they lost both coordinators
because that's what happens when you
have success uh steikin goes to
Indianapolis again and goes to Arizona
but they promoted from within on the uh
the offensive side and brought in Sean
to side defensively at least siriani did
a really great job there's a
in Philadelphia there's just a good
feeling around that team there always
has been and you and I have talked about
the fact it starts at the top and Jeff
Lurie has owned that team for over a
quarter of a century now hard to believe
Jeff so you know a relatively young man
uh it's a classy organization they do
things right it just it feels good
around there can you win the Super bowl
of course you can you're gonna win the
Super Bowl once every 32 years if you
look at the low of averages but that is
a it's a very good team it's a really
good team again can they get back sure
they can and it's not like it was I
think in the old days where there was
this you know Super Bowl hangover yeah
where you work your ass off all season
long you got to the Super Bowl and you
lost I'll never forget I did the uh
I did the the 49er charger Super Bowl in
94 with the Steve Young through six
touchdown passes Jerry Rice had a
gigantic day they killed him they killed
him and we had Bobby Ross who was the
coach of San Diego in a meeting the next
year early in the season or in the
preseason and I said to Bobby in the
meeting how long did it take you to get
over that game he goes I'm still not
over it
so it's something that's situent in the
crore of people it has to
um but I think you you I think the in
today's world Dan you gotta look past
that and I think shariani and that
organization is looking past them the
problem is as you know it's five months
to the Super Bowl you can't get there
tomorrow you got to do the grunt work
and grind it out between now and
February
what was your first NFL game that you
called like
I was thinking about this the other day
with our good friend Richard Eisen
October 3rd 1971 long story on the
announcer for the Cincinnati Reds NBC
calls me to do a buffalo at Minnesota
game
a point-to-point game it's the year of
the years of the blackout so the game is
not even on television in Minnesota in
Buffalo it's on a uh Chef station
because NBC is also doing the World
Series and the playoffs in baseball and
so football gets preempted by the World
Series so the game is on the UA shift
station in Buffalo only point to point
it's you've got to sit there you know
with rabbit ears and move the antenna
around in that game the Minnesota won
the game 19 to nothing but Grant was the
coach
in that game were O.J Simpson and Al
cowley's
I did them in 1971.
so then you go
that's forever ago wow but I still
remember I worked the game with Johnny
Morris the former you know Bears wide
receiver and the Bears the Bears have
had such problems obviously offensively
in finding the right quarterback through
the years that Johnny still dots the
record book he's got a lot of records
for the Chicago Bears still to this day
great to talk to you uh how's the golf
game
the golf game is horrendous it's
somewhere between awful terrible and
horrendous so you always give me a tip
leave me with a tip leave Johnny Miller
that doesn't work four syllables right
you take it back you take it back with
Johnny
and bring it through with Miller
yeah and then what well you got to hit
the ball
it's a good idea you know Hey listen
when I play in a tournament which I
haven't done in a while but when I
played in the ATT in 2008 at Pebble
Beach or 5 000 people are lining the
first Fairway yeah do you know what my
swing thought was I couldn't get it out
of my head please God don't let me whiff
yes I and people think you're a good
golfer if you play in these pro-ams you
know especially the a t and I would be
like move out of the way and then they
started laughing and I go no no no I'm
serious move out of the way I don't want
to hit anybody
on the 14th hole and I'm on television
it's the one time CBS takes a shot of me
and they have like 2 000 people they
call it Club 15 at Pebble Beach and it I
Tee It Up and the crowds you know
yelling at me and yelling my whole
career with me and now all of a sudden
it gets deathly quiet and now I can't
feel myself and I stepped away and I
looked at the crowd and I went anybody
got an Ativan so
uh keep fighting the good Fido
you too Dan thank you buddy man that's
Al Michaels he'll be on the call
Thursday night the uh amazonians Prime
video that'll be at 8 15 Eastern Vikings
at the Eagles